I'm glad you guys are Naruto's first enemies
[Music] Stay behind me
until I tell you to and
prepare for the Cloth Binding Jutsu [
Music]
Why, why can't I keep up?
[Music]
With you now, you can't keep up with me.  You don't
realize that you can't win.
[Music]
You hesitated to wear white back then,
and inside you couldn't hide the turmoil caused by the death of evil.
[Music]
But now you're feeling emotionless.  It's a tool.
But let's end this battle.
Hey, Kakashi-sensei, what do you think about this?
They
were enemies, but...
[Music] I
liked you.
This is weird.
[Music] No.
Me too
[Music] Shi
[Music] Your
deaths and tears
were the very bonds we had with each other. As a shinobi,
I too have
many things to protect.
One of these new arrivals who spits Samsa.  Well,
their last enemy was me.
[Music]